نجود العتيبي فنانه سعوديه شابه بترسم من
لمن كان عمرها ثلاث سنوات واليوم صارت
نجود اول فنانه وامراه خلينا نقول وسعوديه
بتنضم لبرنامج اقامه دريفن بايتش في
استوديو 13 في دبي لدعم وتعزيز مسيرتها
المهنيه الاقامه هذه هي احدث مراحل
المبادره اللي هدفها دعم المواهب الصاعده
في الشرق الاوسط
الى جانب
الى جانب هذه المشاركه نجود لها قصه رائعه
وملهمه حقيقه مع الفن الفنانه الشابه
بتعاني من ضعف السمع لكنها قدرت تستغل هذه
العقبه وتحولها لمصدر الهام في فنها وصارت
تستخدم هذه العقبه في الرسم
وترسم الاصوات زي ما سمعتوا بالضبط بترسم
اصوات كيف ومن فين جاتها الفكره وفي كمان
غيرها من الاسئله احنا في تفاعلكم
استغلينا وجود وجود في دبي وقابلناها عشان
نسمع قصتها منها شخصيا فانا اترككم مع هذه
المقابله واعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله
في الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام الاسبوع في
امان الله
يا اهلا يا نجود كيف حالك الحمد لله كيف
حالك الحمد لله انا تمام خلينا نبتدي من
المعرض قبل ما نرجع نتكلم عن الفن ودخولك
للفن والكلام هذا كله بس كلميني عن اخر
معرض
انه الافتتاحيه للمعرض في لقامه الفنيه
اللي هي مع دريفينج وانا اعتبر اول فنانه
اكون فيه واول فنانه سعوديه اول فنانه
كامراه مثل مره جميل خلينا نرجع شويه
لوراء واصلا انت كيف دخلتي هذا العالم
الارض الفن
القصه تضحك لان انا بدات وعمري 3 سنين
وانا صغيره بيبي لانه اكتشف بابا يرسم كنت
اقول يعني وانا لين دحين فاكره هذا الموقف
اقول كيف يحول البحر على اللوحه كيف كيف
بنقلها صوره كامله فكنت شوفي احركها
بالفرشه عرفتي فبعد فتره اتعلم انه هو صار
يعلمني حتى كان يقول لي انه انت الوحيده
اللي تتعلمي ما حد ما حد من اخواني كان
يتعلم
بس بعدها صرت ارسم صرت حتى كمان ماما تقول
لي صرت ارسم خالاتي لما يجي ارسمهم وارسم
تفاصيل اللي انا شعري منكوش
بس بعدين لما صار عمري خمس سنين
اصبت بالاضات السمع بس اهلي ما عرفوا انه
ما برات الاعراضي عرفتي بس
كان عرض من اعراض مرض اخر يعني مرض الحمى
اللي دمج الاطفال
فما حد كان يعني انت ما حد كان شايف انه
ايش المشكله بس بعدين لما صرت في الثانوي
عرفوه وصاروا ينتبهوا انه انا صرت حتى
اسمي ما اسمع لهم الا لو احد دقن عرفت
انتبه
منعزله وكنت حاصله انا يعني عالقه في مكان
واحد
فبعد قررت انه اغير لانه عارفه اللي
كل الفنانين يعبروا عن نفسهم ايش هو نفسهم
انه انت مين كيف عيشتي وانا كنت ناكره هذا
الشيء عرفتي انه انا كنت ناكره انه لا انا
ما عندي ضعف سما انه هذا الشيء حيتغير
ممكن حيتزبط ممكن حتعالج انه كنت ناكره
نفسي
بالضبط فيعني حتى اوقات كنت استحي دايما
انزل شعري لما البس السماعات عرفتي ولا
احط الطرحه مرتاحه بس انا ماني مرتاحه
عرفتي
فانا قررت هنا انه عشان اصير ارتسناش حول
الفنانه ناجحه لازم نعبر عن نفسي لازم
اطلع للعالم سواء يعني مو شرط انه اتكلم
لا انه على الاقل حتى من خلال شغلي عرفتي
فغيرت انه اقرر الستايل حقي خليته الفن
التجريدي بس مره كان صعب الموضوع ما كان
فمره رحت البحر مع صحباتي
مره واضح وانت لابسه سماعاتك يعني بمعرفتي
فانا هنا ما كنت عارفه كنت من جد يعني من
جد سامعه كل شي مزبوط فسويت بحث عن هذا
الشيء وقتها دخلت
فاكتشفت انه الاصوات بحر كبير يعني دحين
احنا في الغرفه هذا في الغرفه هذه هم
مصممين الغرفه هذه عشان الصوت يوصل لك
ويوصل لبث بس ما يوصل لبره عارفه مصممين
الصاله كبيره انه الصوت يوصل لبعيد على
حسب المسافه من فوق البحر لما تتكلمي ما
في ما في جدار انخبط عرفتي البحر يعني
الصوت لما تتكلم الصوت يروح ويجيكي على
طول يعني ما في حواجز
حتى كمان يقول لك زمان الناس اللي في
الصحراء كان اسمه من بعيد انه مسحه ايه
فكل هذا اخذتيه وبدات انك بتعبر عنه في
اللغه بالضبط طيب وبعدين يعني انت ايش
بتحاولي توصلي من هذا كله لو قلت لك مثلا
قشري صالتك في هذا الموضوع ايش بحاول اوصل
اول شيء انه المتعبر عن نفسك ترمو سهل لما
تتقبلي نفسك مو سهل كل الناس لما تشوف
الكود والاشياء هذه بيرسل
موضوع مره صعب صحيح
بس خصوصا لما يكون عندك شيء وكلنا كلنا
مختلفين ما احنا زي بعض بس اختلافاتنا هذه
هي اللي تميزنا
ولازم يعني يعني انا مختلفه مو انه انا
خلقته للمختلفه عشان اكون احسن منك ولا
شيء لا انا عشان اشجعك عشان ادعمك عشان
تشوفي انه اه هي قدرت تسوي كده انا اقدر
اسوي كذا انا لما اشوف فنانين وصلوا لهذه
المرحله انا يعني
هموني عرفتي مو بس كمان فنانين رسمين اي
احد يعني عنده طباخ ممكن يكون يمر بظروف
صعبه هذا الشيء مره يهمني
يعطيني
الموضوع وتقبلتي
يعني
هو هو لما قدمت انا في مسك وقلت لهم قصتي
انا توقعت
بس مره كانو مرحبين فيني عرفتي اللي اللي
بتحس الناس عندهم عطش القصص هذه
اوكي طيب والان المستقبل ان شاء الله
المستقبل
شوفي للحين افكر انه ان شاء الله هدفي
الوحيد انه زي ما له نفسي ان شاء الله
الهم غيري الناس
اللي عندهم صعوبات تعلم او صعوبات زي في
السمع او عندهم او ذوي الهمم فان شاء الله
يعني اكون انا مصدر الهام لهم هذا الشيء
اللي انا اطمح له صراحه باي شيء ثاني غيره
ههه لو خصوصا كمان يمكن انه في حراك فني
كبير كمان في السعوديه
وان شاء الله يعني يوم من الايام بتشوفوا
اعمالي منتشره في السعوديه تكونوا تشوفوا
كمان
مره شكرا لك وبالتوفيق دائما
تكلمت عن نفسي ههه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]